[Music]
good morning Modell today we shall be
hearing from a sexual health expert I'm
here to start an open conversation about
s e
ex
[Music]
didn't you one cover cause yes
it's a new turn no more Clinic no more
drama you can't give up and once
opto-video
I beat someone but I know it's not true
I can't do dirty talk my [ __ ] tastes like
kimchi neighbors moved on and so have I
[Music]
she let me back in I went tell everyone
that your school is full of cheese
I think I just had a very small orgasm
I was wondering who liked to go out with
me
I think already usual we are guys have
sex you finally get a girlfriend and
she's basically your sister we're not
gonna pretend everything's okay cuz it's
not is there something going on between
you and Maeve Maeve work out with me
courses in a busy I think I might be
broken
sex doesn't make us whole so how could
you ever be broken
tell anyone already oh yeah yes
[Music]
this is entirely about money it's good
to be back in business
[Music]
[Music]